ضربات الروسيه صاروخيه جديده تستهدف انحاء
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وتلحق اضرار تحتيه
ومنشات الطاقه هجمات وصفت بالاوسع منذ بدء
الحربه او وفق مسؤول عسكريا اوكراني مضيفا
ان الدفاعات اسقطت 37 مسيره روسيه في
منطقه كيف ووسطت اكلات ان الضربات الروسيه
تسببت بانخفاض استهلاك الطاقه في اوكرانيا
الى النصف
الانفجار تهزت العاصمه الاوكرانيه تكيف
كما امتدت شمال شرق اوكرانيا في خان كيف
هو تسببت الضربات باضرار فاتحه للبنيه
التحتيه وتحديدا انظمه الطاقه ووافق عمده
المدينه الامر الذات ينطبق على اخر سؤال
في وقت افاد حاكم منطقه
جنوبي اوكرانيا برصدي ما يصل الى 60
صاروخا روسيا متجهه الى المجال الج
الاوكرادي
ضربات التزامنت مع توقعات للجيش الاوكراني
تتعلق بشن روسيا هجوما جديدا على كييف في
الاشهر الاولى من العام المقبل بعدما تركز
القتال منذ اشهر شرقي البلاد وجنوبها فيما
يسعى الجيش للمحافظه على خط الجبهه الحالي
الممتد من الجنوبي الى الشرق ما عدا
بفقدان مزيد من الارض بعد ان احرزت القوات
الاوكرانيه تقدما الاشهر الماضيه في منطقه
قصف صاروخي روسي وشلل يضرب موارد الطاقه
في اوكرانيا لتبقى معادله الحرب هناك بين
البردي والظلام مع تواصل دوي ضربات الجويه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه